[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est on est on avec un
petit peu dans une sorte d'atmosphère
technophiles est bon pour ne pas dire
techniciste en fait en pensant que le
développement technologique le progrès
technique et capable de résoudre à peu
près tous les problèmes afférents à
l'activité humaine aux activités
humaines et en l'occurrence les
problèmes de sécurité
ce qu'il faut réguler ces usages bien
évidemment et ce que l'on se dirige vers
une régulation stricte et les conforme
aux libertés fondamentales et aux droits
fondamentaux ça j'en suis je ne suis pas
sur l'europe pour l'instant est quand
même excessivement en retard par rapport
à la chine et parer aux états unis bien
entendu ça me fait penser évidemment une
anecdote d'un ministre italien qui
disait quand il nous conte une
innovation n'est les américains en
format marché et les finnois la copie
les européens la réglemente et on est là
dedans je pense un peu à rebours un peu
en retard
on réfléchit à être finalement non pas
de leurs de leçons mais se devait un peu
bonne conscience et on cherche
finalement à cataloguer les risques
c'est exactement dans ce sens là qu que
la commission européenne finalement
s'inscrit aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
faut être réservé et sceptique en tout
cas c'est mon avis
le principal problème de l'europe est
qu'elle ne comprend pas ou feint de ne
pas comprendre
il faudra sans doute de démêler le
démêler exactement ce qu'il en est c'est
que le droit en tant que telle n'a aucun
intérêt si derrière il n'y a pas une
puissance capable à la fois de le
modeler en fonction de ses intérêts et
de le faire appliquer sur le reste des
acteurs sauf que c'est oublier que les
deux grands concurrents les deux grands
rivaux stratégique de l'union européenne
que sont la chine les etats unis eux
n'ont jamais respecter ces règles
même les états unis qui ont une
rhétorique libéral très forte c'est une
rhétorique libéral qui est surtout
adressé au reste du monde et surtout pas
à eux mêmes
les etats unis sont un pays
protectionniste et je n'hésiterai pas à
dire aussi que à l'instar de la chine
selon un modèle différent certes mais à
l'instar de la chine
c'est une économie administrée qui
défend ardemment ces entreprises et qui
n'hésitera jamais à distordre la
concurrence de telle sorte que ces
entreprises soient favorisés y compris
et surtout au détriment de d'entreprises
européennes qui elles n'ont pas cette
puissance publique
cet état stratège derrière pour les
défendre par delà les règles du droit la
loi ne pourra pas tout la loi n'est pas
une potion magique pour les entreprises
c'est pas grâce à une solution
je dirais réglementaires ou une
directive qu'on va tout de suite avoir
des champions d'intelligence
artificielle en europe
il faut d'abord des cerveaux il faut
d'abord des ingénieurs il faut d'abord à
marcher il faut un soutien il faut du
financement
c'est quand même ce qui manque
aujourd'hui depuis depuis plusieurs
années aux dizaines d'années en europe
parce que précisément on le lui le
combat aujourd'hui est largement perdu
par les européens alors on essaie de se
rattraper et c'est peut-être heureux
qu'on réfléchisse en matière de
souveraineté
je pense que pour pour une fois entre
guillemets on réfléchit en matière de
souveraineté et on se dit comment
finalement récupérer le retard
comment comment le rattraper et on se
dit que finalement à partir du moment où
on fait une loi ou le marché est
concerné c'est très important ça veut
dire que les entreprises américaines et
chinoises vont devoir respecter le cadre
européen
elles vont devoir s'y plier ou sinon
elles passeront elles passeront à la
caisse et les et la cité européenne
naturellement
la leçon sont probablement plus plus
plus respectueuse d'un prêt du général
ceux ci et ça c'est très ceci est très
large comment comme réflexion peut-être
qu'on va s'orienter vers une
réglementation ou la souveraineté
européenne va prendre le pas sur sur le
marché c'est l'ambition de l'europe
presse qu'elle sera soumis ou pas dans
cette rumeur rien ça va prendre du temps
parce qu'il y aura encore des navettes
là aujourd'hui c'est un projet de loi
par la commission y aura des échanges
avec le parlement il y aura un lobby
excessivement féroce évidemment des
entreprises spécialisées dégâts afin
notamment d béate et x chinois je sais
que les députés européens reçoivent
plusieurs dizaines dizaines de milliers
de mails ces jours-ci depuis plusieurs
semaines justement pour leur expliquer
comment il faut penser la loi en france
et en europe donc il ya il ya une
pression excessive en force sur le sur
les parlementaires européens depuis
quelques temps bien avant d'ailleurs que
la loi sortent même que donc elle sort
dans les médias donc ça va être un
combat qui va être rude
la loi n'est pas encore sorti le projet
a été annoncé et il fait réfléchir
pour l'épauler système dit a dit à haut
risque bonjour envoie vers le texte pour
savoir exactement quand il s'agit pour
ces systèmes dia il faut une sorte une
forme de il faut se une certification et
moi ce que ce que je pressens ses
erreurs c'est pas du tout inscrit dans
le texte ya rien de précis là-dessus
mais ce que je pressens c'est que ces
organismes de contrôle ils seront
rémunérés parce qu'ils devront contrôler
c'est à dire un petit peu comme les
cabinets d'audit
dans le cas du dj toros investissent
actes ou du dj toro market act c'est à
dire en fait que ces organismes qui sont
censés être indépendants le texte le 10
ils sont censés être indépendants
risquent d'être rémunéré parce qu'ils
sont censés contrôler de façon
indépendante dans ces cas là on se doute
bien que notamment les grands acteurs
qui ont la capacité de financer très
fortement ce type d'organisme et bien
passeront entre les mailles du filet de
la la conformité de la certification et
à ce moment là que le texte sera voué
sans doute à l'inanité